i have a 20 20 20 rule that i follow
four
twenties first 20 your first 20 years
have grown up don't make big mistakes
don't don't make royally big mistakes
and you know which ones i'm talking
about i know what you just want
to start saying make the small ones
you're going to do no one's you don't
walk on water
just don't make them in the car with a
guy that's selling
kilo coke and you're in there and he
gets arrested you get arrested
distribution you go get a felony just
like dude you could
if you can prevent those big ones good
for you right happened
happen try to clean it up but hopefully
first 20 years you don't make the big
mistakes next 20 years
find one industry lock in
become the best make a lot of money
minimum 10 million
upwards of 100 million dollars if you
can make it for net worth or
in regards to what do you mean by 10
million buy 40 have a net worth of 100
million
okay buy 40. buy 40 have a net worth of
100 million i love you patrick
buy 40 have a net worth of 100 million
minimum because you're gonna listen
anything you give 15 to 20 years so as
an industry
if you give it everything you got you're
gonna make that kind of money
no question no question about it so you
may say i want to be a great podcaster
you take this thing to
10 million subs you're killing it all of
a sudden spotify comes up to you says 85
million
contract we're giving you you don't know
what's going to happen right there's a
business model to the madness as well
then from 40 to 60 is taking that money
you made
and using creative you still can manage
your businesses
but using creative on what you want to
do next you always wanted to do movies
now you can do it you want to do music
now you can do you want to go buy art
now you can do it you wanted to go out
there and do
real estate investments maybe be a small
owner of a sports team
now you can do it and then 60 to 80
politics and giving back
very simple so for me it's all about the
plans
20 20 20 20 and you know exactly what
you want to do next so if you're 30 or
like by 39 i should be doing xyz
so that's why i wrote that book
[Music]